dort wird ihnen präsentiert von 100
elektrischen nissan leaf
[Musik]
ab 15 von heribert förster und stau ist
die cdu müsse
hier sind sie nicht
bis man schon durcheinander meine
wohnung system nicht das verstehe ich
die aufregung
ja
[Musik]
ich war ein bisschen schweres waren als
zu spät
macht gar die rundgänge scheint man zur
anhörung zu spät punkt das zweite
einbürgerungsverfahren ist das strengste
in ganz europa zwar gibt es nur einen
schweizer pass aber über 2000 wege hin
zu bekommen
das entspricht der anzahl gemeinden in
unserem land zum ersten mal haben
kommunale behörden in allen vier
sprachregionen zutritt zu ihren sehr
vertraulichen anhörung gewährt bei dem
entscheidenden schritt vor der
kommission müssen die bewerberinnen und
bewerber ihre swissness unter beweis
stellen und zeigen dass sie das
räderwerk dass unser land antreibt bis
ins kleinste detail kennen
willkommen in der einbürgerungs fabrik
bekommt bei fabrik die swisspor
schweizers la fabbrica die schweizerin
schweizer machen
[Musik]
so in der bildung lehnert die wirtschaft
kamen schnell man dran
[Musik]
schon vor sieben monaten tauchte andreas
intensiv damals ging es um den
kantonalen test er hat ihn mit bravour
bestanden heute gilt es die nächste
hürde zu nehmen
der gebürtige ostdeutsche muss vor der
einbürgerungsbehörde seiner gemeinde
antraben hätte mir zuliebe deshalb
braucht für die pensionskosten besser
unmittelbar vor dem gespräch prüft
annina hermann mitglied der behörde
andreas thoß sie noch einmal kritisch
bei fragen könnte sich auf das wissen
der gemeindeschreiberin verlassen
wenn man von allem eine überforderung
bekommt hinzugehen
die vorbereitung ist grausig ja weil man
weiß nicht was ihm da widerfährt
am besten man im lexikon der schweiz und
lernt auswendig ja
mir nichts
[Musik]
was sie da vor über die betrieblich
begangen hat und konfiguration hatte
bedarf in negativen abstriche und darum
nicht anruft wird aber sich nicht
relevanten sich die große stunde ist
gekommen
andreas steht unter enormen druck zum
stress den die eigene anhörung auslöst
kommt noch die erinnerung an das
scheitern seiner tochter lisa
[Musik]
vor fünf jahren ist seine tochter in
eben diesem saal vor eben dieser behörde
abgeblitzt
nach dem negativen entscheid hat lisa
die schweiz definitiv verlassen
andreas blieb allein zurück läuft es so
dass erst und fragesteller annina
hermann gehörte der behörde an die lisa
prüfte und durchfallen ließ sie will
nicht auf die anhörung von damals zurück
kommen sie nicht an stimmen und was hat
sie bewogen spitzenwerte lebt hier und
möchte irgendwie auch am
entscheidungsprozess mit teilnehmen und
das hat man nun ohne stimmrecht hat man
nicht im verhältnis
fühlen sie sich da heute meint befindet
sich dabei integriert und wendet sich
das handy kontakt mit dem vermieter sehr
sehr guten kontakt mit ihnen zusammen
wandern in die grünen zusammen
wir sind zusammen urlaub und marina
herrmann stellt die fragen auf
schweizerdeutsch
für sie ist es unvorstellbar dass ein
kandidat integriert sein soll der die
landessprache nicht kann
[Musik]
bitte machen sie es sich bequem
wir sind nicht da um eine test
abzuhalten um ihnen fragen zu stellen
wir machen hier nicht auf gemeinde
prüfen wir sind hier und sie kennen zu
lernen weil wir den gemeinderat
vertreten
13 jahre nachdem er aus eritrea in die
schweiz geflüchtet ist sitzt david mit
seiner tochter elena vor der
einbürgerungskommission ob die beiden
die schweizer staatsangehörigkeit
bekommen wird sich in der nächsten
halben stunde entscheiden
in diesem kurzen treffen werden wir uns
mit ihren kenntnissen über unser land
befassen
okay gut zuerst fielen dank ihnen allen
ich heiße david meister und komme aus
eritrea
ich wohne seit fast zwölf jahren im
tessin hier habe ich alles gemacht
die habe ich mein leben geändert habe
eine lehre als plattenleger gemacht aber
als ich dann als plattenleger gearbeitet
habe hatte ich probleme wegen klebstoff
allergien
ich musste den beruf aufgeben und habe
einen anderen weg eingeschlagen
ich habe mich zum verkäufer umschulen
lassen beim media markt in landschaft
was machen sie heute
ich habe immer noch im mediamarkt
perfekt fahren sie fort
meine frau macht eine ausbildung als
geschäftsführerin im gastgewerbe
außerdem arbeitet sie als dolmetscherin
im ganzen kanton tessin nach david sorge
sein befristeter umschulungs vertrag
läuft bald aus und sein arbeitgeber hat
ihm noch nichts versprochen
sein lohn reicht nur knapp für die ganze
familie
die integration eines der kriterien die
das gesetz für die integration vorgehen
ist die wirtschaftliche integration
dh dass die person für sich aufkommen
kann muss hier im tessin habe ich
geheiratet
meine beiden kinder sind hier geboren
sie spielen beim fc rapid alle beide
gehen sie mit an die spiele an den
samstagen und sonntagen begleite ich sie
wenn ich arbeite geht meine frau mit
nehmen sie während ihrer freizeit am
leben in lugano teil am stadtleben ja
meine musik feste sind zum beispiel das
corner oder während des karnevals dann
bin ich in der stadt unterwegs auch mit
den kindern
es gibt kandidaten die wissen nicht mal
den namen des parks an dem wir uns
befinden
der chemiepark oder kennen nicht den
namen des flusses der durch die stadt
fließt der karate während die anhörung
von david in lugano weitergeht hat im
kleinen engadiner kurort der
alltagsstress familie corona cardoso
wieder fest im griff
den entscheidenden schritt
die anhörung vor der
einbürgerungskommission haben sie hinter
sich
doch der entscheid steht noch aus
automatisch
ich lebe jetzt seit 26 jahren im engadin
ich habe alle restaurants dagegen
getestet und mich dabei für eigene
rezepte inspirieren lassen warum
pauli hofft dass er mit all seinem
wissen vor der einbürgerungskommission
punkten konnte ungeduldig machte er auf
den entscheid ob seine familie die
staatsbürgerschaft bekommen
es ist ein kräftezehrender weg aber es
lohnt sich
ich finde so wichtig dass wenn du das
wort zu hause über bevor man andere land
dass du auch integriert und interesse
hat also nicht einfach nie ich hatte
mich auf den test gefreut
und wenn ich ihn bestimmt kann ich sagen
dass ich es verdient habe und gelernt
habe
im moment steckt clara in einer anderen
wichtigen phase ihres lebens
sie muss sich entscheiden wie es
beruflich weitergehen soll
ihre praktikumsstelle hat sie nicht
zufällig gewählt die 15 jährige spricht
vier sprachen fließend eine ideale
voraussetzung in einer region die ganz
vom tourismus lebt ich weiß noch nicht
was ich nach der schule machen soll
welche lehrstellen im gastgewerbe oder
doch lieber im tourismus das hat ein
bisschen miteinander zu tun und ich kann
all meine sprachkenntnisse brauchen
[Musik]
einige hundert meter vom engadiner hof
entfernt im gemeindezentrum entscheidet
thomas walter und seine
einbürgerungskommission über das
schicksal der familie corona cardoso
die zuschauer wählen projekt vor der
familie kronen
ich schaue er bekannte dass sie vorgänge
könne
hier werden die anhörungen von kleineren
delegationen durchgeführt um den
eindruck einer gerichtsverhandlung
möglichst zu vermeiden
der schluss entscheid wird dann im
plenum gefällt
langdorf sie sind zur vorbereitung auf
das gespräch sind sondern die
bloggerinnen beantworten aber sind auch
an einer selbe frage gestellt da ergänzt
und widerruft punkte glaubt der familie
warum mit und küssen dürfen
als mike aufgestellt und der mexikaner
sicher angedacht die familien das ist
schwer miteinander und sie sind von sina
verbunden
denker und das verstehen
das gibt relevanten gesellschaft gelebt
dass wir wissen ja was die varia machen
sich der fall klar city dem ribery will
das gibt keinen grund idee des bürgers
mit jenen bürgern werden also die reden
braucht dauert die sind bestens
integriert die herrliche aussätzige
fühlen und dennis gesprächen aggressive
formen sagt sie
[Musik]
das bürgerrecht auf gemeinde ebene ist
nur ein erster schritt
einbürgerungswillige müssen dann noch
das kantons bürgerrecht erlangen bevor
sie die schweizer staatsbürgerschaft
erhalten alle drei elemente braucht es
zwingend und vollwertiger schweizer
vollwertige schweizerin zu werden
im altehrwürdigen palazzo chigi co in
lugano wird jetzt ermittler in die zange
genommen
nach dem neuen gesetz dürfen
einbürgerungswillige ab 12 jahren
angehört werden können wir dann los mit
unseren kurzen gespräch in welche schule
gehst du in die sekundarschule
entwicklung dieses jahr habe ich die
achte klasse abgeschlossen und zurück
müsse schon bekommen
10 69 keine sechser aber im vergleich
zum letzten jahr wo ich viele fehler
hatte habe ich dieses jahr keine einzige
vier nur lauter viereinhalb und fünf ich
habe halt mehr gelernt meine mutter sagt
wir sollen uns nicht stressen lassen uns
aber auch nicht blamieren kannst du sag
nur dinge die du auch denkst dann bin
ich rein ich habe gesagt was ich denke
und ehrlich auf die fragen geantwortet
du so niedrig traumberuf mein traum wäre
es sängerin zu werden
aber dieses jahr habe ich mich vor allem
mit architektur befasst
ich möchte später mal architekten werden
weißt du ob wir youtube große normen in
der architektur haben sie haben uns
einen prospekt gegeben in dem einige
schulen aufgelistet sind eine der
bekanntesten architektur schmieden
ich glaube es gibt ein ich bin einfach
hin und habe ihre fragen beantwortet das
wasser aber keine obligatorischen
schulen im tessin gemacht sie können
sich in geografie geschichte und
wirtschaft aus für sie ist es einfach
sie kann auf jede frage antworten für
mich ist das schwieriger deshalb musste
ich ja auch so viel lernen
die kommission in lugano hat mehr
mitglieder als die meisten anderen in
der schweiz präsidiert von einem jäger
mitglied ist sie klar rechts
positioniert und spiegel das politische
kräfteverhältnis in der stadt den 13
personen im saal gegenüberzusitzen
verlangt david alles ab
[Musik]
musikinstrument andreas hat keine ahnung
was da auf ihn zukommt freienbach hat
einen katalog mit 120 muster fragen
zusammengestellt aus denen annina
hermann 80 ausgewählt hat die wichtigste
frage sind sich einmal die wunden bereit
was zählt sind was durch sind
geografisch weiß wunder ist denn er
hätte gern drei arbeitgeber bietet meint
friedhöfen
dann ist noch gegen uns ist demnach
pflanzgarten architektur
aber große filmemacher
großer form auf
ach so ja denn mein prinzip namen und
ärgerten
mehr welt.de die stimmung schlechter
bevölkerung ja keine zeit
man weiß nicht was auf ihn zukommt und
kann nur hoffen dass man nicht versagt
ja prüfungsangst kommt dann schon und es
ist furchtbar eigentlich jetzt im ganzen
kanton
also ich fand es wichtig sind in schweiz
ganz wichtiges dokument den sechs
kommissionsmitgliedern gegenüber fühlt
sich andreas immer unwohler und in
lugano werden die fragen thematisch
breiter interessieren sie sich für
politik vita politiker gezielt es ihn in
lugano in der schweiz bis jetzt nicht
wirklich
ich lese die zeitung
was mir an der schweizer politik am
meisten gefällt ist dass das volk
entscheidet das berührt mich richtig in
meinem land ist das nicht so oder
entscheidet immer die regierung wissen
sie was das gebäude dieser palazzo hier
für die stadt lugano bedeutet dieser ort
an dem wir uns befinden
wie heißt er und wozu dient er ist das
rathaus das rathaus zwei dinge sind hier
untergebracht der gemeinderat und die
stadtregierung danke ich übergebe meinen
kollegen das wort zuerst bitte für
calden
ich hätte eine frage an den vater aus
reiner neugier
weshalb haben sie das tessin gewählt und
nicht etwa italien sondern gerade das
tessin
die wahl ist sie ein bisschen
in der schule in eritrea wären alle genf
kennen weil genf eine weltstadt ist also
ich lebte aus eritrea wollte ich
unbedingt nach 11 weil nicht wie
entscheiden
als wir in der schweiz ankamen und ja so
wurden wir nach ungarn geschickt viele
kommen nach zürich andere nach genf so
ist das halt und waren sie schon mal in
genf zweimal einmal allein und einmal
mit meiner tochter hat es dir gefallen
welche stadt gefällt mir besser das
kommissionsmitglied scheint vergessen zu
haben dass geflüchtete die asyl
beantragen nicht frei entscheiden können
wohin sie gehen
der verwaltungsapparat entscheidet für
sie die fragen werden schwieriger sie
haben gesagt dass ihnen am politischen
system der schweiz gefällt dass das volk
entscheidet wie entscheidet das volk
macht referenten es entscheidet ob ja
oder nein
wenn ein gesetz kommt oder wenn etwas
passiert wenn die regierung oder die
gemeinde etwas anstößt entscheidet das
volk ob es das will oder nicht
es gibt noch andere arten wie man in der
schweiz entscheiden kann
sie sagen wenn man mit einem vorschlag
der regierung nicht einverstanden ist
kann man entscheiden ob man in den arm
nimmt
es gibt noch eine andere form für das
volk um mitzubestimmen
auch wenn das gesetz klar festhält dass
sich einbürgerungstest und anhörung
inhaltlich nicht überschneiden sollten
halten sich manche kommissionsmitglieder
nicht daran
david ist verunsichert ich glaube es
gibt zwei sachen nicht nicht falsch
liege nicht nur eine
es gibt das eine wenn das volk nicht
einverstanden ist aber in der schweiz
haben die bürgerinnen und bürger auch
die möglichkeit sich zu entscheiden
sie bestimmen mit die bürger können
vorschläge machen
der regierung etwas vorschlagen und wie
nennt man das
red
referendum hat nein das andere die
initiative die volksinitiative die
volksinitiative jedes mitglied der
kommission kann fragen stellen
aber es gibt die grundregel dass wir den
bewerbern keine fragen stellen die ein
teuschnitz bürger nicht beantworten
könnte initiative referendum das sind
konzepte die als kompliziert gelten und
generell nicht zu den klassischen fragen
die wir den bewerbern stellen noch eine
frage in ihrer familie welche sprache
sprechen sie da zu hause italienisch und
oft auch die gremien sprechen sie noch
andere sprachen sprechen arabisch
englisch und ein wenig arabisch wie
redest du mit deinen geschwistern liebe
kollegen gibt es weitere fragen da
bedanken wir uns und wünschen ihnen
anhand vieler folgen der schule
mir gibt es kraft wenn er mal bei mir
weil sie meine tochter ist sie beruhigt
mich ich weiß nicht wie das wir wähler
ist aber für mich ist das wichtig
[Musik]
ich wusste doch dass sie sich was zum
ballett risikofragen werden wer ist hier
das genie
ich habe es gewusst und bin und du
konntest nur dank mehr richtig antworten
danke hast du bestanden papa für david
ist es noch zu früh um sich zu freuen
es steht zu viel auf dem spiel jetzt
kommt das lange warten auf den entscheid
in freienbach versucht sich andreas
anfrage 59 im kanton schwyz haben die
gemeinden die wahl entweder werden die
kenntnisse der gesuchstellerin und
stelle bei der anhörung getestet oder
die einbürgerungswilligen legen einen
sprach- und grund wissenstest ab
rheinbach hat entschieden beides zu
machen ist ja nur eine wichtige sache
bundesräte wie ich ist die bundesrichter
verdammt ist die bundesräte es war weg
es war wie ein schwarzes loch ja und die
befreiung hört ja deswegen auf die idee
weiter meinte bach ist status fünf
ortschaften wie heißen die gerichte
legislative letzte stufe eins 16 asse
[Musik]
ab stimmiges thema auf bundesebene mit
zwei traditionell typische schweizer
sport die anderen fragen die dann
gekommen sind ich habe ja noch nicht mal
mitgekriegt dass ich die beantwortet
habe weil immer noch da wenn man dann
immer die bundesräte wie soll man dann
da irgendwie eingebürgert werden
die hilflosigkeit der havarist viele
prüfungen habt ja das sieht so ein
blackout hatte kannte ja nicht von mir
also ganz klar welche stände auf dem
kopf und trinkt
nicht um leben und tod
ja schon wie einem briefing
grafikbeschleuniger trieb es sie nicht
was verstehen sie unter gewalt training
[Musik]
für andreas ist dass die eine frage zu
viel wie vor fünf jahren seine tochter
kommt er vor der behörde ins straucheln
[Musik]
nach 50 minuten und über 80 fragen ist
die anhörung vorbei andreas atmet
erleichtert auf die schiene der
schweizer pass ferner als heute
die werte
[Musik]
ich habe so viele fragen nicht
beantwortet ja ich habe mehr mit mir
selber hat als es mit der inklusion also
montieren
kartelle von meiner tochter auf einer
erinnerung ja dass die der meinung sind
ja hat sie vorbereitet und das durch
das war schon sehr sehr sehr makaber
erfahrung
[Musik]
viele monate sind seit dem beginn des
verfahrens vergangen nun hat die
warterei ein ende endlich ist die
ersehnte post da anna und es sich nicht
verkneifen einen blick in den beruf zu
werfen
aber sie hat den umschlag wieder
zugeklebt um die überraschung nicht zu
verderben
was du ihn auf das ist so wichtig wo sie
könnte wichtig sein wäre das hier ist
das von papa wichtiges papier dich bist
du zufrieden mit entschied des blattes
von pontresina hat klare corona des
bürgerrechte gemeinde pontresina 11
schön also wirklich das ist ziemlich
großer teil glaube ich schon verbindet
ich werde das laminieren lassen und
draufschreiben das wichtigste der welt
akzeptiert da das auf jeden fall ab dass
ich gerade
doch dahinter
wir sind auch wichtig es ist etwas
zusätzliches in meinem dasein
ich fühle mich als fahrerin die sache
weiß wird
[Musik]
die erste august das ist der
nationalfeiertag den feiere ich jedes
jahr
ich bin unterwegs wie alle anderen auch
wir feiern so wie die anderen mit
freunden mit der familie im tessin kann
david endlich aufatmen
der positive entscheid der stadt lugano
ist gerade eingetroffen
seit ich in der schweiz bin war es mir
wichtig den ersten august zu feiern weil
ich hier lebe und arbeite
mein ganzes leben ist hier deshalb ist
es auch meine nationalfeiertag
das ist nicht nur eine frage des passes
nicht weil ich mich einbürgern lassen
bildet feiere ich den ersten august für
mich war das immer ein wichtiger tag
[Musik]
für david ist es ein sommer voller guter
nachrichten endlich hat ihn sein chef
einen unbefristeten vertrag angeboten
das fest das feuerwerk ich liebe das und
freue mich jedes jahr daran
[Musik]
da kommt ein gewitter auf das wird
schwierig mit dem feuerwerk bei dem
regen
[Musik]
auf der alpennordseite ist die stimmung
im keller nach der verpatzten anhörung
wartet andreas noch immer auf seinen
entscheid
[Musik]
kino geführten unbedingt noch von
anderen kollegen mit dem zusammen
schulungen gemacht habe gehört habe da
glaube ich nicht dass es geklappt hat
der sensor ist durchgefallen erst durch
gefallen dürfte im nächsten jahr noch
mal wiederholen
ich habe schon immer angetan und noch
mal
das schicksal
wie sichert man sich vorm reden sind und
da jedes mal wie etwa 2500 franken zu
bezahlen
man muss ja nicht betteln
[Musik]
heute hat meine tochter gewesen habe
gesagt dass ich nicht noch mal probieren
wir ja nicht irgendwo auftreten
erst jetzt nach der eigenen erfahrung
vor der einwanderungsbehörde begreift
andreas was seine tochter durchgemacht
haben muss für einen jungen menschen
wenn der so auseinander genommen wird
ist der weg noch schlimmer als für
jemand der schon
[Musik]
lange nur auf der welt ist und viele
bitte gerichtet und fehlt erlebt hat
aber für so einen jungen menschen ist
sind ja nun richtig furchtbar
[Musik]
meine kinder sind alle hier geboren und
fühlen sich als schweizerinnen und
schweizer wenn ich sie frage ob sie ihre
dreher oder schweizer sind sagen sie
halb halb sie wissen doch gern wo er
riet er ist jetzt nur der schweizer pass
in reichweite ist wird eine reise nach
eritrea greifbar
seit 13 jahren auf david auf ein
wiedersehen mit seinem vater
er würde ihm so gern seine enkelkinder
vorstellen
[Musik]
kaufmann
brille
das ist wahnsinn
[Musik]
wahnsinn
der bürgerrechts bewerber erfüllt die im
gesetzentwurf vorgesehenen einführungs
voraussetzung das wetter wird dass
bürgerrechte meine freienbach erzählt
[Musik]
er hatte ein total leer gegen den
beschluss kann beschwerde umwelt wenn
man das kriegt dafür käme ich mir ein
ich freue mich wahnsinnig dass herr
gerade deshalb ist es gibt eine person
die er sofort informieren will seine
jüngste tochter lisa steht total linie
und wenn man überlegt wo man herkommt ja
vor 30 jahren war mauerfall ja vorher
hätte man noch nicht einmal irgendwo da
die dachte irgendwann mal in der schweiz
arbeiten zu gehen ich werde den
schweizer staatsbürger werden zu können
ja das habe ich gerade
naja jetzt lädt handy auf hätte man klar
sagen das ist ausgeschaltet ist als
strom leuchtet ja ich bin noch ein
bisschen neben ja der ersten blick ja
doch schweizer ihr musst mich nochmal
genau ist war alten bis hin zu neu für
mich komplett bürgerrecht
russland hat ich danke danke danke danke
es waren sind ach ja nicht fassen
[Musik]
auch für david und die kinder wird die
schweizer staatsbürgerschaft greifbar
sie setzt dem schwierigen
flüchtlingsstatus am ende an diesem
abend sieht die zukunft für die familie
rosig aus
ich lebe für sie für ihre zukunft
meine kleider kommen voran in der schule
sie sind die zukunft
ich denke jetzt an sich
[Musik]
im märz 2020 hat das corona virus alles
still gelegt auch die verwaltung blieb
nicht verschont
einbürgerungsverfahren wurden teilweise
gestoppt nicht im oberengadin in einem
abgelegenen bündner tal
[Musik]
wie elegant bardot
nach 30 jahren in der schweiz geniessen
paul und anna diesen tag er ist
abschluss eines langen steinigen der
schweizer pass das ist die kirsche auf
der torte
jedes jahr erhalten 45.000 menschen den
schweizer pass eine stolze zahl
und doch hat die schweiz eine der
tiefsten einbürgerungs raten in ganz
europa
[Musik]
dort wurde ihnen präsentiert von 100
elektrischen nissan leaf